[Music]
welcome back
breaking news this morning we have brand
new apprehension numbers for the month
of june from our source brandon judd the
president of the national border patrol
council
here are the unofficial numbers they'll
probably go higher because this is just
up until
uh today june border encounters
nationwide 174
000 in the month of june 39 000 plus got
aways in other words those people were
seen on surveillance
uh they got away we have no idea what
their intentions are they are now
in america according to brandon these
people are going everywhere
little rock charlotte des moines and new
york city and miami both major hot spots
for gotaways
tucson arizona also a real hot spot for
gotaways joining me right now is
congressman lee zeldin he's a member of
the house foreign affairs committee
he's also running for governor of new
york right now and good morning to you
congressman
your reaction to these new numbers as we
uh expect
some of them to go to new york what can
you tell us
it's a staggering crisis at our border
right now
reality setting in we have as members of
congress
an oath that provide for the common
defense we should be
a funding department of homeland
security and ice and customs and border
patrol we
should be strengthening our borders
enforcing our rule of law
and we talk about people who come across
our border but as you look at those
numbers
we also have to take account for the
things that come across
the drug trafficking the arms
trafficking the story behind
these numbers often times we're talking
about labor trafficking and sex
trafficking as well so it's important
for
those in government to provide all the
resources to law enforcement to do their
jobs
safely effectively because this
is not just something that crosses a
border but it's something that quickly
spreads to cities and communities all
across our country
yeah and of course president trump
cleaned all of this up
but the biden administration overturned
it we're going to speak with the
president in just
about 30 seconds time here but real
quick what is your plan to turn around
what's taking place in new york you've
got murder rates
skyrocketing in u.s cities 35 percent up
in atlanta
24 up in l.a minneapolis up 45
crime also skyrocketing in new york what
is the plan
support law enforcement more not less
reverse cashless bail here in new york
keep qualified immunity enact a bill of
rights for law enforcement that
recognizes their inherent right to
self-defense that gives them the
resources they need to
ensure they aren't unfairly targeted i
was raised in a law enforcement
household
i'm hearing it from all across our state
from people from all walks of life
they want to strengthen public safety in
our state
all right lee zeldin it's great to see
you this morning thanks very much a
little
abbreviated interview there we
appreciate your time this morning
congressman
we'll keep watching congressman lee
zeldin